Lia has been out for about a week now so
let's cover some pros and cons Pro this
is kind of a cheap one but this is
probably the best Souls like that has
been made by someone other than fromsoft
not only does it really feel like a
fromsoft game in a lot of ways it still
has its own unique flare so it doesn't
feel like a total ripoff con the game
does have a lot of surprise second
health bars in boss fights I like these
in games occasionally but they should be
a surprise Liza P does it quite often I
feel like this should just be reserved
for very specific bosses PR the
animation is absolutely stellar and I
think that particularly stands out
consider ing this world so creative that
it's actually fun just to be introduced
to a new enemy type to see how they move
potential con I feel like things weigh a
lot weight management is obviously very
important in this kind of game but it
feels like it is kind of extra with Liza
P that things just a real weighty Pro I
think the level design is incredible con
goes hand in hand with the last Pro I
think it's maybe a little too linear
sometimes I think it's very smart in
combat but it's like always very clear
where you need to go and it doesn't make
backtracking very exciting